[Music]
okay welcome back everyone good
afternoon welcome back
hope lunch was okay
thumbs up on lunch okay so we're ready
for our next talk here before we get to
that talk I'd like to mention that
Hillsdale College has over the past few
years I've been involved with online
courses we those online courses cover
such topics as the Constitution history
economics and the great books among many
other subjects speaking of great books
and great authors our latest course is
titled the young Jane Austen North anger
Abby and I'm happy to report that today
we have over 1.5 million students signed
up for the college's online courses and
so I encourage you to join that growing
number if you haven't already you can
visit our website and you will find the
current course and all of our past
courses are archived and available for
watching for free okay our next speaker
our first afternoon speaker is Edward J
earlier he's become something of a
regular at Hillsdale College events both
on and off campus I've known him for a
long time now since 1994 when I went to
Claremont for for graduate school now
one thing about being in graduate school
what that meant is I and my fellow
students didn't have a real job we had
to get up 4:00 in the morning so that
meant we could keep him up late at night
talking about American politics and
political philosophy which he was always
happy to do for as long as we wanted him
to even though he did have a real job
so for that we we were very grateful and
I'm delighted he could be here
dr. ill earned his PhD in government
from the Claremont Graduate School and
then went on to a long and distinguished
career at California State University
San Bernardino where he is now professor
emeritus of political science he's
published numerous articles on
constitutional topics in leading
political science and law journals and
he was a member of the California
California Advisory Commission on civil
rights as well as he he also served on
the California constitutional revision
Commission Commission
he is the author of the American polity
co-author of the founders on citizenship
and immigration and I just found out
before coming up here he's authored a
new book which is to be released soon
titled John Locke and James Madison on
the right to property the rise and fall
of constitutional government in America
I should also mention that in the fall
of 2016 he was a visiting distinguished
professor of politics at Hillsdale
College his topic today is immigration
and I would like to ask you now to
welcome to the podium Professor Euler
[Applause]
thank you Tim I do indeed remember those
Rockets days when you were a graduate
student we had much fun it's always a
pleasure to appear before a Hillsdale
audience I know I will have a receptive
audience and a knowledgeable audience
but I think I am going to have to give
you an apology in advance for the
strident tone that I'm about to adopt
and perhaps even a pedantic tone because
the more I see our country in danger and
the more I see our country departing
from its founding principles the more
frantic I get and the more impatient I
get so I apologize in advance I think we
probably all remember when President
Obama was attending a NATO summit in
2009 he was asked whether he believed
America was exceptional his answer
unfortunately was unexceptional
I believe in American exceptionalism he
said just as I suspect that Brits
believe in British exceptionalism and
the Greeks believe in Greek
exceptionalism president didn't seem to
realize that if all countries are
exceptional then no country is
exceptional in the president's view to
say that America is exceptional would be
the assertion of a kind of unqualified
arrogance or pride that is rejected in
the world of value relativism that Obama
and his progressive allies inhabit where
it is illegitimate to claim superiority
for a nation or its principles yet Obama
considered himself to be the legitimate
heir to Abraham Lincoln this is a
remarkable therefore that he seems to
have forgotten Lincoln's famous
statement about what made America
exceptional which I take it to mean what
made America great in 1859 Lincoln made
these remarkable this memorable
statement all honored to Jefferson he
said to the man who in the concrete
pressure of a struggle for national
independence by a single people had the
coolness forecast and capacity to
introduce into a marilee revolutionary
document an abstract truth applicable to
all men at all times and so to embalm it
there that today and in all coming days
it shall be a rebuke and a stumbling
block to the very harbingers of
reappearing tyranny and oppression
Lincoln was of course referring to the
Declaration of Independence and its
central principle that all men are
created equal and that they have been
endowed by their creator
with the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness this was not merely
a revolutionary document where one set
of rulers was exchanged for another but
one in which for the first time in the
history of the world a universal
principle derived from the laws of
nature and nature's God became the
ground for establishing constitutional
government there have been countless
revolutions in history but none where a
country had ever declared itself to be
dedicated to the principles of natural
law and natural right that was truly
exceptional and it was those founding
principles that made America great
now progressivism and ideological
liberalism has tried it's best to expel
those principles from our political life
and they may have succeeded in doing so
because progressive liberals speak
openly today about living in a post
constitutional world where
administration and the administrative
state have replaced the Constitution as
a source of our most authoritative
opinions and our most authoritative
principles a post constitutional world
they openly speak of it the Constitution
has been replaced by administration now
we also remember a statement made by
Secretary of State John Kerry in May of
2016 when he advised his fellow citizens
to prepare themselves for a borderless
world although the secretary didn't say
so he knew the implications of his
statement a borderless world will be a
world without sovereign nation-states
and consequently a world without the
exclusive citizenship that attaches to
separate and equal nations and here I
use the language of the Declaration of
Independence separate and equal Nations
when the sovereign nation sate state has
given way to the universal homogeneous
state citizenship will be replaced by
what has been called universal
personhood now historically
constitutional government has been found
only in the nation state where the
people share a common good and are
dedicated to the same principles and
purposes the goals and principles that
animate a people may be universal as in
the case of the Declaration of
Independence but the pursuit of those
principles can succeed only within the
confines of a separate political
community the fact that all men are
created equal and thereby possess equal
natural rights is a universal principle
applicable to all human beings but for
that principle to become a political
reality a separate nation had to be
created dedicated to that proposition we
can speak of citizens of the world but
everyone knows that this is something
that can be imagined but cannot exist in
reality the homogeneous world state let
us say the European Union on a global
scale will not be a constitutional
democracy it will be the administration
of universal personhood without the
inconvenience of having to rely on the
consent of the governed
it is and will be government by
unelected and unaccountable bureaucrats
much like the burgeoning administrative
state that is today
expanding its reach and magnifying its
power in the United States Universal
persons will not be citizens they will
be client or subjects rights will be
superfluous because the collective
welfare of the community will have
superseded the rights of individuals now
more than a century ago the Supreme
Court of the United States announced
what was considered the settled sense of
the matter when it remarked that it is
an accepted maxim of international
sovereignty and essential to self
preservation to forbid the entrance of
foreigners when in its dominions or to
admit them only in such cases and upon
such conditions as it may see fit to
prescribe immigration control was thus
thought to be an indispensable aspect of
sovereignty and a central to
self-preservation a nation that cannot
control who enters the country and who
becomes citizens is not sovereign it is
that simple it is clear however that
progressive liberalism no longer views
self preservation as a rational goal of
the nation-state
rather in the view of ideological
liberalism self preservation and
national security must be subordinate to
openness and diversity America's
immigration policies we are assured
should demonstrate our commitment to
diversity because an important part of
the American character is openness and
our commitment to diversity is an
affirmation of who we are as an American
as Americans as an oft
repeated phrase has it if this carries a
risk to our security it is a small price
to pay we are told the willing
assumption of risks adds authentic
authenticity to our commitment tolerance
is easy and can be done casually
it doesn't require real commitment
but once risk is involved the commitment
becomes real
it becomes authentic but we are asked to
be to believe something utterly
incredible that the American character
is defined only by its unlimited
acceptance of diversity a defined
American character devotion to
republican principles republican virtue
the habits and manners of free citizens
self-reliance what of course be
impermissibly exclusive in a word
impermissibly american the world
homogeneous state only recognizes
openness tolerance of diversity and
acceptance as its highest virtues these
are the virtues of universal personhood
it must condemn exclusivity as its
greatest vice it is the nation state
that insists on exclusive citizenship
and immigration policies that impose
various kinds of restrictions we are
asked to make the same commitment to
diversity in accepting sanctuary cities
and since I'm from California
also sanctuary states if some citizens
become victims of crime as a result this
is yet another demonstration of the
depth of
our commitment our willingness to offer
up human sacrifices as it were on the
altar of diversity and openness risking
the lives of ordinary citizens is a
demonstration that we are serious about
diversity and are willing to make
significant sacrifices not just tolerate
diversity but willing to make to take
risks in the name of diversity in
California my Governor Jerry Brown is
especially serious he is a very very
serious human being and he cannot afford
to be since he is protected by his
omnipresent security detail at the same
time he worked to disarm the people of
California why so that their commitment
to the diversity will become even more
authentic now President Trump wants to
eliminate sanctuary cities in sanctuary
state and he has declared war on
California to demonstrate his commitment
not only to preserving the Union but to
preserving the lives of citizens for
Trump self-preservation is still a
rational goal of the nation state
security is not subservient to openness
and diversity I think there is little
doubt that the president is on solid
constitutional ground in his war on
California now our politicians and
opinion leaders public intellectuals
professors assorted other progressive
liberals proclaim their commitment to
diversity almost daily
chanting the same meme diversity is our
strength it is of course obligatory to
say this in today's regime of political
correctness it's something that we must
say but how does desert diversity
strengthen us we seem to think that
diversity is desirable for its own sake
that it is an end in itself is it ever a
force for unity or cohesiveness or is it
a source of division and contention does
it promote the common good and the
friendship that rests at the heart of
citizenship or does it promote racial
and ethnic division and something
resembling the tribalism that prevents
most of the world from making
constitutional government as success
when is the last time you heard anyone
in Washington talk about the common good
we are used to hearing talk about the
various stakeholders or interest groups
but not much about what the nation has
in common this should not be surprising
to anyone greater diversity means we
inevitably have less in common and the
more we encouraged diversity the less we
honor the common good
any honest and clear sighted observer
should be able to see that diversity is
the solvent that dissolves the unity and
cohesiveness of a nation and we should
not be deceived into believing that its
proponents do not understand the full
impact of their advocacy
diversity of course marches under the
banner of tolerance but is in fact a
seminary of intolerance here I use the
words of a famous philosopher it
enforces its ideological liberalism with
an iron fist
that is driven by political correctness
which I believe is perhaps the most
ingenious and insidious device for
suppressing freedom of speech and
political dissent ever invented ever
invented political correctness however
might have been stopped dead in its
tracks at the beginning but Republicans
refused to do so
when they had the opportunity now listen
to this in the election of 1980 some of
you may remember this I do Ronald Reagan
promised to end affirmative action with
the stroke of a pen by rent rescinding
the executive order issued by Lyndon
Johnson that created it this promise was
warmly received by the electorate in
that very important election but Reagan
failed to deliver his promised repeal
too many Republicans have become
convinced that they could use
affirmative action to their advantage
that the largesse associated with racial
class entitlements would attract
minorities to the Republican Party by
signing on to this regime of political
correctness Republicans were never able
to mount an effective opposition to its
seemingly irresistible advance
today any Republican charged implicated
or associated in any way with racism
however tendentious outrageous
implausible exaggerated or false will
quickly surrender often preemptively
this applies equally to other violations
of political correctness homophobia
Islamophobia xenophobia and here the
parallel parallelism ends sexism and a
host of other so-called irrational
prejudices after all there is no
rational defense against an irrational
fear which is what presumably all the
phobias are publicans have rendered
themselves defenseless against political
correctness and the established wing of
the party doesn't seem overly concerned
as they frequently join the chorus of
progressive Democrats in denouncing
Trump's violation of one or another
Canon of political correctness only
president Trump seems undeterred by the
Terrorism that rests at the core of
political correctness and he alone seems
determined to resist it good luck mr.
president in addition to the affirmative
action executive order in 1965 there
were other actions that were part of the
Great Society meant to transform America
in fundamental ways the Civil Rights Act
of 1964 was sound legislation authorized
by the 14th amendment that sought to
abolish racial discrimination in
employment but the administrative
agencies will the full cooperation of
the courts
quickly transformed it's laudable goals
into mandates mandates that required
racial discrimination to achieve racial
balance or racial proportionality in
hiring and promotion the Voting Rights
Act of 1965
similarly sought to ban racial
discrimination in voting it too was
transmogrified into an act that required
racial discrimination in order to
achieve proportional results in
elections proportional results were
touted by a palpable fiction as the only
reliable evidence of free and fair
elections the Immigration Act of 1965
was a kind of affirmative action plan to
provide a remedy for those races or
ethnic groups that had been
discriminated against in the past
Caucasian immigrants from European
nations had been given preference in
past years now it was time to diversify
the immigrant immigrant population by
changing the focus to third world
nations primarily from Latin in South
America and Asia those areas that had
been discriminated against in the past
the goal here as some scholars have
slowly come to realize was to diversify
the demographic composition of the
American population from majority white
to a majority of people of color there
was also some recognition that those
coming from countries that were the new
focus of the immigration bill were more
likely to need the ministrations of the
welfare state and therefore more likely
to be captured by the Democratic Party
the party of the administrative state
white middle-class Americans in the
1960s and 70s were often referred to as
these selfish classes because their
principal interest was improving their
own lives educating their own children
and contributing to their own
communities they showed no inclination
to support diversity and the kind of
authentic commitment to the new openness
that was being advocated by ideological
liberalism they stood as a constant
roadblock to the administrative state as
they stubbornly resisted pleas to
increase taxes increase immigration and
expand the welfare state once these
selfish classes were no longer a
majority they would be powerless to
resist demographers say that sometime
around 2040 is the day of reckoning
whites will not be no longer will no
longer be a majority and will sometime
thereafter have to endure the fate they
have inflicted on others for so many
years
this radical demographic change will be
due almost entirely to the immigration
reform that was put into motion
by the Immigration Act of 1965 of course
it is entirely a fiction that the
American political system produces
monolithic white majorities that rule at
the expense of what are called discrete
and insular minorities whites as a class
have never constituted a majority
faction never in the history of our
country and the Constitution was
explicitly directed at preventing such
majorities from forming
the fact that among a host of other
considerations the Civil Rights Act of
1964 was passed by a supposed monolithic
white majority to promote the Equal
Protection rights of minorities ought to
Balai the fact that it was a majority
faction ruling in its own racial class
interests
now we must also not forget that
President George W Bush was also an
advocate for a borderless world he
frequently stated that family values
don't stop at the border
you probably remember him saying that
Bush was a supporter of amnesty and a
path to citizenship for illegal aliens
and he clearly indicated that certain
universal values transcended the
nation's sovereignty we also remember
that Bush called himself a compassionate
conservative and it was on full display
here on these issues of immigration and
citizenship he said on several occasions
that we should be more compassionate to
our less fortunate neighbors to the
south but also the same kind of rhetoric
was used by President Ronald Reagan when
he signed the immigration reform and
Control Act of 1986 the Act provided
amnesty for three million illegal aliens
and was touted at the time by President
Reagan as a way of humanely dealing with
the issue of illegal immigration in his
signing statement Reagan said the act is
both generous to the alien and fair to
the countless thousands of people
throughout the world who seek legally to
come to America the act was supposed to
be a one-time only amnesty
in exchange for stronger border control
only the most naive in Washington
believed that the promise of border
control would be honored
illegal immigration continued unabated
the act of course also fueled
expectations even demands for additional
amnesties even that amnesties become a
regular feature of the of American
immigration policy delays in
implementing new embassy amnesties have
been treated with contempt by
immigration activists and proffered as
evidence that the American people lack
compassion and here I ask you to recall
jeb Bush's statements during the 2016
presidential primaries almost any
clear-thinking observer can see that
compassion is not a sound basis either
for foreign policy or immigration policy
compassion is more likely to lead to
contempt than gratitude in both policy
areas failure of the 1986 amnesty should
be a clear reminder of the youthful
useful Machiavellian adage that in the
real politic of Foreign Affairs is
better to be feared than loved fear is
more likely to engender respect
whereas love or compassion is more
likely to be regarded as a contemptible
sign of weakness in 1984 Reagan had
received 30 percent 37 percent of the
Hispanic vote but after the 1986 amnesty
the vote of his successor George HW Bush
declined significantly to 30 percent
granted Bush was no Reagan
but such ingratitude seemed to puzzle
Republicans Donald Trump in the 2016
presidential campaign appeal to the
importance of citizens and borders in
other words Trump took his stand on the
nation-state and nationalism against the
world homogeneous state he reminded the
nation that the people are the sole
source of legitimate Authority under the
Constitution and a B end in appealing
directly to the people in the election
of 2016
president Trump succeeded in defeating
both political parties the media
political professionals pollsters
academics and the bureaucratic class the
administrative state he defeated all of
them and all of these groups formed part
of the bipartisan cartel that had
represented the entrenched interest of
the Washington establishment for many
years the cartel has not given up it is
fighting a desperate battle to maintain
its power
Trump has few allies in this battle with
the cartel whether he will succeed or
not is an open question but if he loses
it will not be a battle that want anyone
else will ever undertake again certainly
no Republican Republicans by and large
do not support the president even on
immigration issues despite the fact that
immigration was a large factor in the
electoral victory Republicans still do
not understand why Trump won the
election they simply do not understand
or refuse to accept the reason for his
victory they view his victory as the
result of unique circumstances they seem
to believe they can therefore high bide
their time until politics returns to
normal and the people regain their
senses funny thing happened as I was
flying in yesterday I was i sat next to
a US attorney and I certainly didn't let
him know that I was coming to speak to a
Hillsdale audience I would probably be
under indictment right now but I
pretended to be sympathetic he actually
knew Muller and he knew Rosenstein I
didn't question him too closely to give
myself away but I learned a lot of
things from him
and he said some things that he ought
not to have said I think because he
thought I was a sympathetic person
but we cannot deceive ourselves about
the fact that the special counsel Muller
is acting on behalf of the Washington
cartel and he is determined to protect
those interests in the intelligence
agencies the FBI and the Justice
Department that were thoroughly
corrupted by the Clintons all of these
agencies the intelligence agencies the
FBI Justice Department were part of the
Washington establishment protecting the
Washington cartel with whom they had
been invested there's simply no question
about that and there can be no doubt
that there is an unspoken bipartisan
political agreement in Washington
Republicans and Democrats alike to
nullify the election of 2016
and that the mauler investigation is in
an integral part of that agreement
establishment Republicans have warned
the president not to fire Muller Lindsey
Graham says it would be an impeachable
offense Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell assures us that it would
provoke a constitutional crisis trey
Gowdy warns us to let Muller do his job
if the president is innocent of
wrongdoing Gowdy says he should act like
it instead of criticizing the special
counsel I guarantee you this that any
special counsel can find some wrongdoing
so I used to tell my students they were
I'd taught the Fourth Amendment
constitutional law they were always full
of stories about they had been stopped
by a policeman and the policeman would
say do you mind if I search your car
and the students always seemed to be
under the impression that they had to
let the policeman search their car and I
would say no you have a Fourth Amendment
right the framers of our Constitution
thought it was important and you should
never waive a right why should you never
waiver right because you always have
something to hide you don't know what it
is but you always have something to hide
one day I was on campus and the campus
where I used to teach is a beautiful
campus a lot of vegetation tall trees
and things like that and I picked up a
feather and it was an eagle feather well
I I had violated a federal law because
all eagle feathers belong to native
persons and so now I had something to
hide
and if the FBI came around investigating
this crime and I lied to the FBI well
you see so it's a good policy you have
honey now a special prosecutor can
always find a crime and the special
prosecutor is after Trump the business
about raiding his personal lawyer now
the special prosecutor that wasn't his
affair but he asked the US attorney in
Manhattan he passed that off with by the
way the associate attorney general's
permission got a warrant from a federal
judge and that's how it started
and that's not how it's going to end
they will be after Trump until they find
something it's very very important that
Trump not be interviewed by the special
counsel because I can guarantee you that
if special counselor and his team of
very aggressive lawyers interview you
long enough you will contradict yourself
and that's all that he needs I can
interview any one of you for eight hours
and I will get you to contradict
yourself you have committed no crime but
once you contradict yourself under oath
you have committed a crime it's that
simple
and there is no doubt that Muller wants
to indict the president now I don't
believe he can indict the president the
president cannot be indicted but you can
see where this is going to lead now
Muller himself has multiple and serious
conflicts of interest we all know about
that they are well known and the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein who
oversees Muller's investigation has
multiple conflicts of interest everybody
knows about this attorney General
Sessions has recused himself you've
heard what the president has said about
that he said if I had known that
attorney general sessions was going to
recuse himself I would not have
appointed him as Attorney General and
president Trump is right about that he
is absolutely right in attorney General
Sessions betrayed the president by not
telling him beforehand he recused
himself for something what that was not
not a conflict of interest why did he do
that well I believe he wanted to dispel
any appearance of conflict by rising
above politics and making a display of
his strict adherence to the rule of law
Rosen Stein and Muller have no such
concerns their only concern is political
the defense of the Washington cartel
which they know is utterly unconcerned
with the rule of law sessions attempt to
remain above politics will serve only to
give free
rain to the political machinations of
the two rogue investigators and their
many co agitators it is sessions failure
to think and act politically here that
is the real danger to the rule of law
the defenders of the Washington cartel
never make such naive political mistakes
the president should fire Muller
Rosenstein and I think even sessions I
think I think that's the president's
inclination he doesn't need my advice
and he won't take it he doesn't even
know that I'm giving him advice if this
provokes impeachment then the president
can take his case directly to the people
as he did in the election of 2016 this
is a fight that Trump can win and it is
a battle he must engage they are trying
to undo the election of 2016
Trump can redo the election reaffirm the
election of 2016 and he can begin there
to reshape and reform the Republican
Party get rid of the establishment he
defeated them once do it again
here's my real pessimism this may be the
last chance to defeat Halle gar key and
restore Republican government now on the
immigration issue the president lost in
the omnibus spending bill it lost
utterly no new Border Patrol agents no
to detention centers they gave him what
30 miles of new border wall but said
those models that you've you've
contracted for none of the new 30 miles
can be in the form of any of those
models just sticking the finger in the
president's eye over the immigration
issue and they everyone knows how
important that was through his victory
in 2016 right in fact I think the
spending bill was an overall victory for
the Washington cartel 2,000 pages of
special interest brokering generally on
the issue of illegal immigration the
Republicans and Democrats are both
reluctant to undertake series reform you
know why easy the Republicans want to
continue the steady supply of cheap and
exploitable labor and the Democrats want
future voters the Democrats count on
periodic amnesties it's good politics
for them why did they not want a daca
deal
they didn't want to dock a deal they
wanted to keep the issue alive
why not good politics sometime in the
near future there may be even voting for
illegal aliens do you know that the
states can authorize it anytime they
want to do you think California won't do
that
the Republicans are thinking only in the
shirt short term labor cheap labor
exploitable labor short-term profits
they are not thinking politically
Democrats always think politically
voters in the long run and I assure you
political thinking will always win in
the long run now Trump wants to stop
chain migration and the diversity
lottery the diversity lottery think of
it it exists for no other reason than to
provide diversity merely for the sake of
diversity those who win in the diversity
lottery also begin chain migration as do
all legal immigrants since 2005 more
than nine million foreign nationals have
arrived in the US by chain migration and
when they become citizen citizens in all
likelihood two-thirds of them will vote
Democrat that's how the Democrats win
they think long term they think
politically we never do one last point
on birthright citizenship
I've spoken to Hillsdale audiences
before about this and I think there's an
in primers issue on this point but one
last point just to remind ourselves
birthright citizenship contributes to a
borderless world any woman who comes to
the US as a legal or illegal alien and
gives birth confer confers the boon of
American citizenship on her child in
these instances America has no control
over who becomes citizens and a central
prerogative of a sovereign nation-state
now we are told by constitutional law
experts that it is a settled issue that
the Constitution adopted the English
common
law definition a birthright citizenship
I recently had a debate with such an
expert who quoted William Blackstone as
his authority Blackstone wrote the
authoritative common commentaries on the
laws of England a work that was well
known to the founders what might debate
upon it seemed not to know was that
Blackstone always referred to birthright
subjects and birthright subject chip
never mentioning citizens or citizenship
in his entire 4-volume work under the
common law anyone born under the
protection of the king owed perpetual
allegiance to the king in return
Blackstone freely admitted that
birthright subject ship was an
inheritance from the feudal system which
defined the relations of master and
servant under the English common law
there were no citizens only subjects the
declaration of independence however
proclaims that the American people are
absolved from all allegiance to the
British crown Declaration of
Independence thus it is clear that the
American people rejected the common law
basis for citizenship and by doing so it
transformed subjects into citizens what
had substituted in the place of
perpetual allegiance to a king is the
consent of the governed with the clear
implication that no individual can be
ruled without his consent consent not
the accident of birth is the basis for
American citizenship James Wilson who
was a signer of the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution and
later a
member of the Supreme Court perfectly
expressed the matter when he wrote in
America there are citizens but no
subjects the principles of the
Declaration of Independence provide the
ground and basis for the unity of the
American people it says we are one
people and we are a good people and the
consent of the government and the
consent of the government a consent
which gives rise to constitutional
government it now I ask you this is it
plausible is it even remotely credible
as our constitutional expert claims that
the founders after fighting a revolution
to reject the feudal relic of perpetual
Allegiance would have adopted that same
feudal relic as the ground of
citizenship for the new American regime
doesn't seem likely the American people
can of course consent to allow others to
join the compact that created the
American nation but they have the
sovereign right to specify the terms and
conditions for granting entry and the
qualifications for citizenship
presumably the qualifications for entry
and Naturalization will be whether those
who wish to enter demonstrate the
capacity adopt the habits manners
capacities independence and
self-reliance of Republican citizens and
devotion to the principles that unite
the American people furthermore it would
be unreasonable not to expect that
potential immigrants should possess
useful skills or professions that will
ensure they will not become victims of
the welfare state
it is also reasonable that immigration
policies should serve the interests of
the American people and the nation they
should not be viewed as
acts of charity to the world an
immigration policy that emphasizes the
diversity weakens us and chain migration
coupled with unsustainable asylum
policies makes orderly immigration
impossible putting America first as a
rational goal it is the essence of
sovereignty and the sovereign nation
state is the only home of citizenship as
it is the only home of constitutional
government and I thank you for listening
to me
[Applause]
well we now have time for a few
questions please raise your hand and
wait for the microphone to be brought to
you
hi um I'm Anna grace Holloway and I just
had a question since you were talking
about sanctuary cities or sanctuary
states and federal law trumps state law
should states be allowed to secede from
the union no state should not be allowed
to secede for the Union because we have
created a perpetual union that's what
the Declaration and the Constitution say
it is a perpetual Union and States
cannot secede unilaterally this was
decided I think in in the Civil War and
I think Trump understands that very very
well and it's odd to see Jerry Brown who
was a liberal acting the part of John C
Calhoun who wanted the secede from the
union over the issue of slavery no this
is a perpetual Union and and Trump has
the upper hand in the in the
constitutional argument article 6 of the
Constitution says this Constitution is
the supreme law of the land and judges
have to apply this Constitution and it
is superior to any state law now the
issue is the Supreme Court says that the
federal government cannot commandeer the
states to enforce federal law in the
States but on the issue of immigration
turning over illegal aliens to federal
authorities once they're released from
jail is not asking the states to enforce
federal law it's only asking for the
cooperation we've already had court
cases on that and California has no leg
to stand on
constitutionally as far as I can see so
no they have no right to secede and by
the way when the states were making
their argument during prior to the Civil
War their argument for secession they
never said it was
active revolution they never said we
have a right to revolution and therefore
we're going to call on the natural right
to revolution to separate ourselves
because revolution was a natural right
that belongs to human beings by nature
because then they would have had to ask
whether or not there was a natural right
to have slaves and whether or not slaves
had a natural right to freedom and they
were smart enough to know that if they
went down the road of claiming the right
of revolution they would have had to
agitate the question whether there were
human rights that belonged to slaves and
they could have it could not have
invoked the right of revolution and they
never did we have time for one more
question yes I I sense the frustration
in the room and certainly I have it of
California basically saying the heck
with everybody where God but in light of
that do you see any authority that would
ever I mean they're clearly violating
the Constitution they're passing laws
that require their citizens and
businesses to violate the law is there
any authority the UC would ever hold
these politicians accountable some of
them should be in jail for what they're
doing no I agree well or do we just go
down the spiral of anarchy
well the Trump admitted Justice
Department has filed a lawsuit in
federal district court in California
which will make its way up several
California cities are also refusing they
have joined the Trump or the Justice
Department lawsuit against California
and one city the city of Los Alamitos by
the way several years ago they have a
racetrack the Los Alamitos racetrack
they found that ms-13 and several drug
gangs from Mexico were laundering money
through the racetrack and this was found
out this has been several years ago now
and this they're especially sensitive to
this you know sanctuary cities business
and who can blame them so there have
been several cities that are now
we're not going to cooperate an Orange
County Sheriff has said that they're
going to turn over you know the illegal
islands are going to cooperate with ice
and the Attorney General Becerra in
California said he's going to arrest the
Orange County Sheriff
and I and I hope he actually makes an
effort to do so because this will may
bring the issue to a crisis point in
California so I think the Trump is gonna
win on this
he's a declared war on California you
know Andrew Jackson in the tariff of
1813 the tariff of 1829 thirty tariff of
abominations when South Carolina's
threatened to secede Andrew Jackson came
down very very hard on South Carolina
and he won in that I mean it could have
been civil war that much earlier and I
think President Trump is claims to be an
admirer of Jackson and he may have
learned a good lesson for Jackson there
so thank you these two printer Kirby
Center speech